Hopefully you were able to type this expression into MathQuill properly. But
just in case it's giving you trouble, here are the keys you need to press to
make it happen. To write log base 3 of x plus 4, we use something pretty
similar to what we did up here. You type \ log and then space to type the word
log. To move down to type the 3 as a subscript, hold down Shift while you press
the button with the minus sign. Then you can enter your 3 and move back up
here, press the Right Arrow key. They may need a parenthesis, an opening one.
And then we have our input, x plus 4. Of course, MathQuill closes this
parenthesis for you on its own. So you don't have to technically type another
one, although you can if you want to. As I said before, you'll get a ton of
practice typing in things like this in MathQuill in future lessons.